l'entrée de nos prochaines célibataire
on a longuement hésité entre une
trottinette électrique et une licorne
mais on a préféré rester au fil de l'eau
c'est le moment de faire débarquer un
peu de testostérone pour ceux qui n'ont
pas fait s au lycée comme moi ça veut
dire des garçons et chez les filles
sarah inquiète pas autant qu'un fer à
lisser en panne et presque la saison des
amours est officiellement lancée tout le
monde y va de son petit rendez vous
encore pire que chez une esthéticienne à
la sortie de l'hiver
j'ai juste vous connaissez le nom de way
of non non non c'est normal
alors pour le pour la deuxième
le deuxième numéro il ya eu aucun
téléchargement est ce que c'est vrai
cette rumeur alors c'est faux je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que même moi
j'ai appelé la personnage que je connais
chef un bon contact chez amazon et j'ai
voulu savoir forcément est-ce que ça a
cartonné est-ce que ça a marché
on m'a dit la politique d'amazon et ça
ne le savait pas c'est qu'en fait on n'a
pas les chiffres et qu'on ne voit pas
les vues contrairement à bien d'autres
voies à travers notre émission on n'a
pas les audiences
notre groupe connaît pas les
téléchargements que ça n'ont jamais
prévient alors doit on sait que ça
semble donc j'imagine chaussée je me dis
ok mais est-ce que vous êtes content
parce qu'il m'a dit honnêtement on est
super contents voit donc mais j'ai pas
de chiffres s'il ya des choses tous les
boulets qui ne communiquent pas et ça
pour toutes leurs émissions et tous
leurs programmes donc c'est pas
spécialement pour l'occasion nous pour
couvrir quelque chose très donc je suis
très contente
alors va se manger plus au coeur de ceux
de ce programme et dematic de amazon
prime où il ya des rencontres ce que
c'est quelque part c'est un peu comme
love story on va pas se mentir un cd cd
rencontre et puis en fait vous ce match
et le thunder love story en fait les
réactifs et les gens sont censés
intervenir dans les aventures des uns et
des autres pour que les choses avancent
ou pas ou qu'elles reculent clash ans
donc c'est assez amusant mais le
problème c'est que ça reste quand même
des rencontres de personnes
et quand ça marche pas eh ben ça marche
pas si bilal vous plaît je vous laisse
avancer d'un pas
[Musique]
oh
mais alors qu'est ce qui se passe pas de
feeling tu avais choisi les batwa
vraiment c'est pour toi si tu avais été
là tu vas retourner sur moi tu vas
parler des champions j'ai trop fort
sympathique mais ça va je suis c'est une
jolie fille tu vois tu me permet d'aller
aux toilettes voisine inquiète au niveau
des nitrates et moi j'étais dans la
maison et peut pas savoir vraiment où la
communication autour des ddd chiffres il
ya points 105 mille personnes abonnées
sur compte twitter c'est pas ouf mais
vous aviez parlé de vendre pas vous hein
c'était pas vous jetez pas vous non plus
qui les attend c'était un certain maxime
j'ai d'abord à l'anonymat pour ne pas
révéler son identité et on avait évoqué
cette europe comme partout l'énorme
salaire de nabila moi je vous dis une
chose c'est greg qui vous donne un
salaire vous seriez bien bête de ne pas
les accepter ça c'est bon d'un point de
vue mais il semblerait magali bertin car
j'ai des antennes partout
oulala voilà le scoop car j'ai des
antennes partout j'ai chaud là vous
n'avez pas infirmer ni confirmer c'est
normal vous êtes son agent ne pourrai
jamais dire s'il a pris 1 millions 10
millions 100 millions sous 1 milliard
mais oui je voulais vous les années
passent et ben voilà c'est comme ça en
revanche c'est pas un million le salaire
de nébias mais pas deux millions à
d'après mes informations exclusives
arriver directement sur cette chose
communément appelé un portable
moi c'est ça dans le henan et mois a
annoncé la somme de 3 millions
[Musique]
annoncée la somme de 3 millions mais
surtout pour l'animation 1 million pour
la communication et un million pour
liste achat main est-ce que magali
pourrait adopter
j'aimerais concédé cite l'agent qu'elle
de benjamin jamais juste une chose il
faut remettre les choses dans le
contexte
amazon prime a fait une opération de
communication extraordinaire amazighs
doivent de lameilhé cette opération de
communication donc moi je ne serais pas
choqué moi non plus vraiment aux données
il a donné beaucoup d'argent pour
utiliser nabila pour porter amazon prime
en jeu mais une soirée ya d y aller il
ya plein d'entreprises qui sont prêts à
payer très cher des influenceurs
aujourd'hui l'investissement de amazon
prime c'est 25 milliards parait-il sais
pas si ce chiffre est exact le cinéma
c'est rien mais c'est monstrueux 25
milliards voilà alors ceci dit si je
peux vous donner un petit conseil vous
avez vous avez des déconnexions
concernant le valence
je trouve que là là là l'épisode dont
lui même et devrait le présenter tel
qu'une émission de télé-réalité est
inhabile à devrait plutôt être sur un
plateau plutôt que d'être en situation
c'est parce que vous en pensez au total
on avec un débrief il serait plus
logique que ça soit vous vous connaissez
très bien là non moi je réponds bah
écoutez moi la saison de jeu l'a fait
pour 500 m
mais même 250 alors moi 200 non
seulement alors outre atlantique c'est
un succès je pense que ça va être la
même chose en france parce que ce qui
est intelligent cette interactivité avec
le public
et en plus elle est très bonne nabila on
peut quand même rendre que des baumettes
elle est bonne mais en effet elle se
débrouille très bien mais si on allait
même mis un studio différents
indépendamment c'est alors et je pense
que ça aurait passé différemment mon
émission c'est mon point de vue je le
partage